in this video we'll quickly look at an
alternative to the conditional random
fields for sequence classification no.1
that's the maximum entropy Markov model
so we've mainly discuss conditional
random fields they'll have one advantage
which is that they are discriminative Li
trained and as we've seen before we
should expect that for a problem where
we have a lot of data that this is a
better approach than training a model
generatively and but we haven't really
discussed whether there were other
discriminative alternatives to the
conditional random field so let's look
at one in this video known at the as the
maximum entropy Markov model so the
maximum entropy Markov model or M EMM is
different from the conditional random
field for one main reason which is that
it is directed so we see here an
illustration of the Emmy mm as a
Bayesian network which means that now we
have random variables that are our nodes
in the network and the edges between the
nodes are actually directed and the
direction of the edges essentially
illustrate the generative story
associated behind the model so in an EM
emm the way we assume that the data has
been generated is that given the whole
sequence so an N emm does not define the
way that the input sequence was was was
generated so it's a conditional model
that does not define a P of X and so
given some input sequence it assumes
that the sequence of labels was
generated from left to right so the
first sequence sorry the first label y 1
was generated only from the information
in X 1 and X 2 so that's for a similar
model than the craf with the context
window of radius 1 so y 1 was generated
and then Y 2 was generated from X 1 X 2
and X 3 and y 1 so all of these guys
were able to influence what value
for the second label was generated and
then y3 was then generated and the value
of y3 was generated from again Y 2 X 2 X
3 and X 4 and so on until we reach the
end of the sequence so so it is a markup
in the sense that the distribution of
one label here is dependent also on the
label previously and the transition so
it's it's a Markov model similarly to a
hidden Markov model but the difference
is that in the hidden Markov model we
would have arrows going down like this
from the labels to the input whereas for
a maximum entropy Markov model the
arrows are this way instead so we don't
actually define the distribution over
the inputs and we just define a
conditional distribution over the labels
and the conditional story goes from you
know we assume that's there was some
generative process for the old inputs
and then the sequence which is generated
instead of the other way around
and so more specifically the probability
of a sequence of label Y given the
sequence of input X is going to be this
product of conditional probabilities
over Y K given the previous label Y K
minus 1 and some information in X so in
the case here sometimes you know for y1
it was only x1 and x2 that influenced
the probability of y1 but in general it
could depend on the whole sequence or so
I just use a general form here and what
would be used for the conditional
distribution the way they would be
factored would be through a something
very similar to either a logistic
regression or a neural network so you
would essentially have a term that would
depend similar to unary log factors that
would depend on some information in the
input and then plus something similar to
a pairwise factor where given the value
at the previous step in
the sequence K minus 1 this we could
express the preference for what the
value we think would be most likely at
white game and that we would normalize
this and now the normalization constant
here would depend not just on X but also
on the value of y K minus 1 so the
normalization constant here Zed would be
the sum over the numerator over all the
potential values for just waiking so
here we don't have a partition function
over the where we have a summation over
all sequences we have only a sum over
the value of the label for the current
position for a given conditional so this
is the model that's not too complicated
to train but has one problem which is
known as the label bias problem
so essentially intuitively what it means
is that the observations that are far
away in the sequence will not impact
predictions that we would be making
early in the sequence and this could be
this can be illustrated in this example
here where we actually have and we can
show that the marginal probability of
the third label given the whole sequence
actually only depends it can be reduced
to the conditional probability of y3
given only the first four elements in
the sequence so in particular because I
have a context window that goes only up
to here well then this this label here
and this label here can be marginalized
out so if I wanted so I want to know
what's the conditional probability of
summing of Y 3 given X 1 X 2 X 3 X 4 X 5
now to do this I will need to
marginalize over these labels here and
these labels here now if I can if I
marginalize those out that I can't
really reduce anything because these
depend on these then the will in they
will have an impact on Y 3 through Y 1
however from this because
the arrows is directed like this and
like that
if I marginalize over Wi-Fi then it's
actually equivalent to just removing
that note and that's because if I write
out the full expression for the
probability of everything including
Wi-Fi and then this marginalizes into a
conditional that only involves Wi-Fi and
this term actually needs to sum to one
so I can just sum sum it out some that
term out and then if I do the same thing
with y4 so now I have this essentially I
have a simpler graphical model that does
not include Wi-Fi and then I can also
integrate out y4 because now it's the
last in my sort of hierarchy or random
variable is the last one which doesn't
have any descendants now and so I can
also integrate it out which means that
this would yield a simpler graph like
that and so now we see that X 5 is not
connected anymore to y3 and so for that
reason we have that y3 given X is
actually just sorry P of y3 given X it's
just P of Y 3 given X 1 up to X 4 so I'm
going fairly quickly over this those
that are familiar with directed
graphical model might see why why this
is is not you can look at a machine
learning textbook on directed graphical
models but that's you know the main
takeaway message here is that maximum
entropy Markov models well they might be
easier to train and I'm just staining
this I haven't really described why but
they're actually very simple to train
they have a problem which is that
predictions in early positions in the
sequence are actually not dependent on
observations further away in the
sequence and so they're not in a sense
fully leveraging all of the information
that might be helpful for predicting a
label at a given position